Die Schweiz -
ein Land, in dem man gerne lebt.
Ein Land, in dem
eigentlich alles funktioniert.
Prochain arrêt: Lausanne.
Bonjour.
Viele Menschen
tragen im Hintergrund dazu bei.
Judith Schnider
leitet den Volg in Laax,
Yann Giuliani begleitet Zugpassagiere
durch die ganze Schweiz,
Yangdol Depön
putzt Hotelzimmer in Luzern,
und Sebastiano Gaffuri ist der
jüngste Gemeindepräsident im Tessin.
Wie leben diese Menschen,
wofür setzen sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie?
Vier Menschen und ihr Alltag -
ein Tag im Leben der Schweiz.
Bellegarde in Frankreich,
4 Uhr in der Früh.
Yann muss zeitig raus.
Wenn ich aufwache,
habe ich oft ein Lied im Kopf.
# Je fais rien que des bêtises,
des bêtises quand t'es pas là.
# J'ai tout mangé le chocolat,
j'ai tout fumé les Craven A.
Er lebt seit zwei Jahren getrennt
und hat einen neunjährigen Sohn.
4.45 Uhr im Bündner Oberland.
Die 52-jährige Judith
macht sich bereit.
Ich stehe morgens gerne früh auf.
Dann kann ich viel erledigen.
Am Abend bleibe ich gerne auf,
aber dann arbeite ich nicht.
Weil ich dann alles liegen lasse,
muss ich es halt
jetzt schnell machen.
Yann braucht 40 Min.
bis zum Bahnhof Genf.
Wegen seines Sohnes ist er
in Frankreich wohnen geblieben.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich ein Kind bekommen würde.
Das war nicht mein Plan.
Ich dachte, ich will keine Kinder,
komme, was wolle.
Aber dieses Treffen
hat alles verändert,
weil sie ein Kind wollte,
und ich wollte auch eines mit ihr.
Und der Tag der Geburt - wow!
Ein Kind! Es hat
meine ganze Mentalität verändert.
Kurz vor 5 Uhr im Valle di Muggio,
ganz im Süden der Schweiz.
Sebastiano ist 28.
Vor wenigen Tagen hat er geheiratet.
Er und seine Frau
wohnen über ihrem eigenen Restaurant
in der Gemeinde Breggia.
Ich liebe das Gefühl,
alleine unterwegs zu sein.
Yann ist 43 und arbeitet
seit acht Jahren bei der SBB.
Sein Stützpunkt ist Genf-Cornavin.
Hier steigen jeden Tag
rund 75'000 Passagiere ein und aus.
Als Erstes muss er
die ganzen Checks machen.
So tanzen wir am Morgen früh.
# I'm horny, horny, horny, horny.
5.30 Uhr in Breggia.
Sebastiano
ist immer der Erste in der Firma.
Seit sechs Jahren
leitet er zusammen mit einem Kollegen
einen Forstbetrieb im Tal.
Ich versuche, das Tagesprogramm
im Kopf durchzugehen.
Und das ist ziemlich dicht.
Sebastiano ist gleichzeitig
seit zwei Jahren
auch noch Gemeindepräsident hier.
Er findet es wichtig,
sich politisch zu engagieren.
Die Schweiz ist ein Land
voller Möglichkeiten,
in dem jeder seine Träume
und seine Ideale verwirklichen kann.
Es ist ein Land, in dem
die Privatinitiative gefördert wird
und sich der Staat
um seine Bürger kümmert.
Ich denke, es ist
eines der besten Länder der Welt.
In der Nähe von Luzern.
Es ist 5.45 Uhr.
Die 26-jährige Tibeterin Yangdol
macht sich bereit.
Sie ist vor zehn Jahren
in die Schweiz geflüchtet.
Beten gehört
zu ihrem täglichen Morgenritual.
Ich fülle die Schalen mit Wasser.
Das heisst,
ich biete Gott Wasser an.
Die gläubige Buddhistin
ist seit vier Jahren verheiratet
und hat
einen zweieinhalbjährigen Sohn.
Sie sind immer noch
im Schlafzimmer.
Sie schlafen sicher bis 7
oder sogar bis 8 Uhr.
Ihr Mann hat gerade Ferien.
Seit einem halben Jahr hat Yangdol
nun endlich auch einen Job
und verdient erstmals
ihr eigenes Geld.
Sechs Jahre lang musste sie auf ihre
Anerkennung als Flüchtling warten.
In Zignau im Bündner Oberland
macht sich Judith ebenfalls bereit.
Oh, das ist so eng hier.
Sie musste nach der Scheidung
ihre vier Kinder alleine durchbringen
und hat erst mit 42
eine Lehre als Verkäuferin begonnen.
Dort drüben, in diesem Laden,
habe ich angefangen.
Das war der Anfang meiner Karriere.
Und jetzt ist er geschlossen.
Es ist so schade, dass er zu ist.
Aber was will man machen?
Das ist so
in diesen kleinen Dörfern.
So, dann machen wir uns auf den Weg!
Vor einem Jahr hat Judith
in den Volg nach Laax gewechselt
und ist dort jetzt Verkaufsleiterin.
Der Weg ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Man ist schnell dort.
Andere müssen 1 Std.
oder weiss ich wie lange fahren.
Und dann ist die Fahrt
noch so schön.
Die 20-minütige Fahrt
ist einer der wenigen Momente am Tag,
in denen Judith Ruhe hat.
Sebastiano ist schon mittendrin.
Er nutzt die Morgenstunden,
um Administratives zu erledigen.
Was seine Karriere anbelangt,
ist er erstaunlich schnell unterwegs.
Ja, ich war ziemlich schnell.
Ich habe die Gelegenheit ergriffen.
Es war zwar mühsam:
Ich habe statt in zwei Jahren
in einem einzigen Jahr
alle Prüfungen gemacht.
Es war schon schwierig und ermüdend,
aber auch sehr befriedigend.
Nach Abschluss seiner Lehre
als Förster in diesem Betrieb
hat er einen zweijährigen Abstecher
in die Deutschschweiz gemacht.
Ich muss meinen Eltern danken.
Ich hatte die Lehre fertig,
mochte meine Arbeit,
begann, etwas Geld zu verdienen,
und hatte überhaupt keine Lust,
in die Deutschschweiz zu gehen.
Aber meine Eltern
haben mich angespornt,
und ich bin gegangen -
zwei Jahre lang.
Wenn ich heute daran denke,
war es eine wunderbare Erfahrung.
Kurz vor 7 Uhr geht's dann
im Valle di Muggio so richtig los.
Am Morgen, wenn die Arbeiter kommen,
geht alles sehr schnell.
Es sind 15 Angestellte,
davon vier Lehrlinge.
Damit sind wir
der grösste Arbeitgeber im Tal.
Seine Firma macht den grössten Teil
der Landschaftspflege hier.
Die Aufgaben sind verteilt.
Zur gleichen Zeit in Luzern.
Ich muss pünktlich sein, pünktlich,
aber ich habe noch 6 Min.
Auch Yangdol fängt um 7 Uhr an.
Sie macht ein Praktikum
als Zimmermädchen
im Hotel Schweizerhof in Luzern.
Fast 38 Mio. Menschen haben letztes
Jahr in Schweizer Hotels übernachtet.
Das ist rekordverdächtig.
Ich mache die Toilette sauber.
Yangdol muss auf der Karriereleiter
ganz unten anfangen,
aber das ist ihr egal.
Es gefällt mir. Den Boden zu putzen,
ist auch nicht so schwer.
Aber bis jetzt habe ich nur
auf der Etage gearbeitet.
Und von hier aus ...
Zimmer sind besser
als die Toiletten.
Sie hatte sich auf gut Glück
als Zimmermädchen beworben,
nachdem ihr eine Stiftung für junge
Mütter diesen Tipp gegeben hatte.
Yangdol will arbeiten
und die Chancen,
die sich ihr in der Schweiz bieten,
packen.
Im Tibet heiratet man ganz schnell.
Man ist ganz jung.
Früher war man mit 14, 15
schon verheiratet.
Das will ich nicht, sicher nicht.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Rund 9'000 Passagierzüge
verkehren pro Tag in der Schweiz.
Über 1 Mio. Menschen
benützen täglich den Zug.
Salut. Ca va bien?
- Tout va bien.
Yann
hat ursprünglich Pöstler gelernt,
aber der Kontakt mit den Menschen und
das Reisen macht ihm viel mehr Spass.
Neun Personen, neun Lächeln -
das ist cool.
Reisen für die Arbeit ist toll.
Überall ist eine andere Atmosphäre.
In Zürich ist die Landschaft anders
und das Wetter.
Wenn ich nach Domodossola fahre,
ist es fast wie ein Feiertag.
Wir haben eine halbe Stunde Pause
und können super italienisch essen.
In Luzern
ist die Umgebung wunderschön.
Und immer komme ich zurück
nach Genf. Es ist geradezu ideal.
Ich liebe Ansagen.
Auch Laax erwacht.
Judiths Filiale ist einer
von 580 Volg-Läden in der Schweiz.
Auf sie und ihre Crew
wartet ein 10-Std.-Tag.
Guten Morgen. Die "Bild"-Zeitung?
"Bild"?
- "Bild".
Sie sucht sie gerade raus.
Das Brot ist das Wichtigste.
Am Morgen kommen alle
und wollen noch ihr Brötchen
oder etwas für die Znüni-Pause.
Du hast die Preise
noch nicht angeschrieben?
Dann mache ich das.
Als ich hier angefangen habe,
habe ich in jedem Rayon
alles durchgemacht,
damit ich weiss,
wie viel Zeit ich brauche.
So kann ich es auch von
meinen Mitarbeiterinnen verlangen.
Ich weiss, wovon ich rede.
Und sie sehen auch,
dass ich mir nicht zu schade bin,
selber anzupacken.
Darum stehen meine Mitarbeiterinnen
auch hinter mir.
Im Süden der Schweiz regnet es.
Neben der Arbeit im Betrieb
und dem politischen Amt
führt Sebastiano
seit einem halben Jahr
mit seiner frisch angetrauten Ehefrau
Claudia und einem gemeinsamen Freund
noch das Restaurant Lattecaldo
in Breggia.
Als wir das erste Mal ausgingen,
hat er gesagt:
"Ich habe nicht viel Zeit."
Und ich:
"Okay, mach dir keine Sorgen!"
Man muss schon sagen:
In der Schweiz scheitern
50 % aller Ehen in kurzer Zeit.
Ich denke, was uns vereint,
ist die Lust auf die Arbeit,
der Unternehmergeist.
Wir ergänzen uns gegenseitig.
Und es ist schon richtig:
Wenn man ein Restaurant
unter dem gleichen Dach hat,
ist es schwierig, ein Eheleben
und ein Privatleben zu haben.
Es ist auch schwierig,
Zeit füreinander zu finden.
Wir nehmen natürlich alle kleinen
Alltagsprobleme mit ins Bett.
Sagt es und ist schon wieder weg.
Sebastiano betreut auch noch eine von
340 Wetterstationen in der Schweiz.
Ich mache das nicht,
weil ich ein Wetter-Fan bin,
sondern, weil ich es gut finde, dass
unser Staat, die Eidgenossenschaft,
die zivile Gesellschaft
damit beauftragt.
Ich finde,
dass es eine wichtige Aufgabe ist,
jeden Tag den Regen zu messen.
Es hat 1,1 cm pro m2 geregnet.
Jetzt schicke ich ein SMS
an MeteoSchweiz.
Und jetzt sollte ich
eine Bestätigung bekommen.
* Klingelton*
Hier.
Ich bekomme 2 Fr. pro Messung.
Vermutlich die SMS-Kosten.
Und ich darf auch jeden Monat
einen Bericht über die Niederschläge
in der ganzen Schweiz anschauen.
Manchmal sage ich aus Spass
zu meiner Frau:
"Wir könnten jeden Monat auf
dem Sofa sitzen und kontrollieren,
wie viel es in St. Moritz
oder im Puschlav geregnet hat."
With that it's better
on the last one.
There are lots of places.
You have two minutes to go.
Coach ten.
Es ist 8.30 Uhr. Yanns Zug
macht Zwischenhalt in Bern.
* Pfiff *
* Beschwingte Musik *
Merci beaucoup.
Guten Morgen. Merci.
Merkt er einen Unterschied
zwischen der welschen
und der deutschen Schweiz?
Wenn man über den Röstigraben fährt,
sagen die Leute weniger "Guten Tag".
Das fällt mir besonders auf,
wenn der Zug nach Luzern fährt.
Aber es ist nicht Verachtung.
Es ist einfach
eine andere Mentalität.
Die Menschen sind konzentriert.
In ihren Augen
mache ich einfach meinen Job.
Sie erwarten nicht unbedingt,
dass ich Hallo sage.
In der Westschweiz ist das anders.
Die Menschen sind ansprechbarer
auf ein "Guten Morgen"
und reagieren auch schneller darauf.
Aber, ob man nun auf Französisch
oder auf Schweizerdeutsch lächelt,
das ist dasselbe.
Ein Lächeln ist universell.
Im Hotel Schweizerhof in Luzern
gibt's jeden Tag
196 Zimmer zu putzen.
Es ist 9 Uhr.
Heute ist mein Tag. 20!
Manchmal 10 Fr., manchmal 5 Fr.,
aber 20 ist bis jetzt
für mich das Höchste.
Andere bekommen manchmal viel mehr.
Manchmal auch 100.
Eine Freundin von mir hat schon
100 Fr. bekommen, 120 eigentlich.
Immer, wenn ich reinkomme,
räume ich zuerst den Abfall weg.
Also.
Da muss ich viel aufräumen. Die
haben viel getrunken und gegessen.
Was ist das Schlimmste,
das sie schon erlebt hat?
Die Leute aus dem arabischen Raum!
Oh my gosh!
Überall Kleider, überall Essen!
Da muss ich viel putzen. Es braucht
viel Zeit, aber es geht schon.
Oder Chinesen. Die machen
auch mehr Dreck als andere.
Aber die Schweizer sind ganz sauber,
ganz sauber.
Da müssen wir nicht so viel putzen.
Asien
gilt als grösster Wachstumsmarkt
in der Schweizer Hotellerie.
Allein die Chinesen
buchten letztes Jahr
mehr als 1,6 Mio. Logiernächte.
Das Tourismusparadies Laax
hat in der Zwischensaison
nur gerade 1'725 Einwohner.
Im Volg ist aber immer etwas los.
So.
Sachen herumschleppen
müssen wir oft.
Daher
ist es ein sehr strenger Beruf.
Guten Tag.
Es ist körperlich
sehr anspruchsvoll.
Man denkt immer: "Ja, Verkäuferin -
das kann jeder Trottel machen."
Aber man muss viel wissen -
v.a. über verschiedene Sachen.
Trotzdem trifft es Judith,
wenn sie das zu spüren bekommt.
Ja, das tut schon weh. Man merkt
dann halt den fehlenden Respekt.
Aber es gibt schon auch andere.
Es hängt auch sehr davon ab,
wie ich reagiere.
Mein Ziel ist es immer,
dass der Kunde sich besser fühlt,
wenn er den Laden verlässt.
Du musst der Typ dafür sein.
Da gibt es solche,
die sich total nerven
und die genau umgekehrt reagieren.
Sie fangen die negative Energie auf,
statt sie ins Positive zu kehren.
Aber das hat sicher
sehr viel mit der Erfahrung zu tun.
Das Valle di Muggio
ist immer noch wolkenverhangen.
Sebastiano ist unterwegs.
Wenn ich diese Brücke überquere,
bin ich nicht mehr zu Hause
oder ich fühle mich
nicht mehr zu Hause.
* Lockere Musik *
Im Naturschutzgebiet Colombera
müssen wir dafür sorgen,
dass die Böden
die richtige Neigung haben,
damit das Wasser richtig abläuft.
Jetzt machen wir zwei Messungen, um
zu überprüfen, ob das funktioniert.
Wir haben hier
einen Unterschied von 20 cm.
Ein Becken sammelt das Wasser,
und das andere lässt es abfliessen.
Trauert er nicht manchmal
seinem alten Leben als Förster nach?
Ja, manchmal vermisse ich
das Geräusch der Kettensäge.
Ich tobe mich dafür
am Wochenende aus so viel ich kann.
Hauptbahnhof Zürich.
Es ist 10.15 Uhr.
Guten Morgen, bonjour, buongiorno.
Salut, ça va?
Yann und seine Kollegin Véronique
haben bereits Mittagspause.
Die SBB beschäftigt rund 27'000
Mitarbeitende in der ganzen Schweiz.
Es hat eine Cafeteria,
wo man richtig frühstücken
oder ab 10 Uhr morgens
heiss essen kann.
Aber ich hatte genug von Sandwiches
und wollte
nicht mehr so viel Geld ausgeben.
Also habe ich begonnen,
mir Salate vorzubereiten.
Es ist angenehmer,
ich esse ausgeglichener
und v.a. weiss ich, was ich esse.
Eigentlich hat er am liebsten Ruhe
in dieser Zeit.
Im Zug bin ich dauernd
mit 700-800 Menschen zusammen.
Das ist ein ständiger Lärm.
Hier ist es erholsam.
* Schwere Musik *
In Sebastianos Restaurant wird
vor dem Mittag seine Hilfe gebraucht.
Mit Essen ist vorläufig nichts.
Ich habe immer davon geträumt, einen
öffentlichen Treffpunkt, eine Bar,
eine Taverne oder ein Restaurant zu
haben, und wir haben es geschafft.
Morgens kann man Kaffee trinken,
mittags den Aperitif,
nachmittags kommen die,
die Karten spielen.
Es funktioniert gut,
weil wir jung sind.
Sie führen das Lattecaldo zu dritt.
Der Koch ist der dritte Teilhaber.
Wenn wir hohe Gewinne
erzielen wollten,
hätten wir in Derivate investiert,
hätten finanzielle Hebel genutzt.
Das Gastgewerbe
ist ein gefährdeter Sektor.
Man muss Lust auf Arbeit haben
und darf keine Angst
vor der Zukunft haben.
Ciao. Saluti, allora.
Mittagszeit im Bündnerland.
Zeit, um in Ruhe zu essen,
das hatte Judith jahrelang nicht.
Als Alleinerziehende in Ausbildung
hatte sie nie Pause.
IN der Schweiz leben rund
eine halbe Million Eltern getrennt.
In 90 % der Fälle
sind die Kinder bei den Müttern.
Ich bin morgens um 4 Uhr
aufgestanden, um zu lernen,
damit ich das habe,
was ich in der Schule brauche.
Dann bin ich in den Laden gegangen
und habe gearbeitet,
habe die Kinder geweckt, zwischen-
durch sind sie in die Schule,
und dann am Mittag
Mittagessen kochen,
nachher Laden,
und am Abend wieder Hausaufgaben
mit den Kindern.
Diese Zeiten
sind glücklicherweise vorbei.
Über Mittag bin ich es gewohnt,
ein Schläfchen zu machen.
Das muss sein. Ganz automatisch.
So.
12 Uhr ist in der Schweiz
Essens- oder wenigstens Pausenzeit.
Yangdol isst
mit einer anderen Tibeterin.
32 % der Mitarbeitenden
im Hotel Schweizerhof sind Ausländer.
Mach zuerst das Bad!
Im anderen Zimmer mache ich das Bad,
du das Bett.
Bis um 14 Uhr
müssen alle Zimmer geputzt sein.
Ich bin jetzt eine Praktikantin.
Aber ab diesem Sommer, ab August,
beginne ich
mit meiner Lehre als Hotelfachfrau.
Ich freue mich sehr,
das ist mein Traumberuf.
Ich habe
schon lange darauf gewartet.
Seit ich hierhergekommen bin,
wollte ich immer im Hotel arbeiten.
Aber wie konnte ich das schaffen?
Das war schwierig.
Viele, die hier in die Schule gehen,
bekommen auch nicht
einfach so eine Lehrstelle.
Ich musste ganz viel Gas geben.
Bis ich meine Bewilligung
bekommen habe,
habe ich mich so stark
auf mein Deutsch konzentriert,
habe versucht,
jeden Tag auf YouTube zu lernen.
Ich habe viel auf YouTube gelernt.
Yangdol hat viel vor.
Mein Plan ist, in Zukunft
eine bessere Arbeit finden,
einen besseren Lohn zu verdienen.
Das ist mein Ziel.
Und auch eine bessere Zukunft und
ein schönes Leben für meine Familie.
Das ist mein Ziel.
Ich bin nicht mehr alleine hier.
Ich habe einen Mann,
ich habe meinen Sohn.
Denen muss ich
ein besseres Leben geben.
Deshalb möchte ich sehr gerne
eine gute Ausbildung machen.
Auf der andern Seite des Gotthards.
Auch Sebastiano
will etwas erreichen im Leben
und hat es mit 28
nicht nur zum Gemeindepräsidenten,
sondern auch schon
in den Tessiner Kantonsrat geschafft.
Regelmässig muss er darum
nach Bellinzona.
Für Politik hat er sich
von klein auf interessiert.
Schon sein Vater war in der FDP.
Sein Hauptanliegen ist,
dass man im Tessin
wieder mehr Eigeninitiative zeigt
und Eigenverantwortung übernimmt.
Wir sind Lateiner und von Natur aus
unternehmungslustig.
Aber ein Aspekt,
den ich nicht so mag
oder den ich nicht so schätze, ist,
dass wir nicht
an unser Potenzial glauben
oder an die Möglichkeiten,
die das Tessin für seine Bevölkerung
schaffen könnte.
Oft fühlen wir uns
wie der Calimero der Schweiz.
Ein positiverer,
ich sage nicht ein aggressiverer,
aber ein stärkerer Ansatz,
unsere Chancen hier vor Ort besser
zu nutzen, würde nicht schaden.
Während es
in der Schweizer Sonnenstube regnet,
zeigt sich der Norden
von seiner besseren Seite.
Nächster Halt Bern.
Als ich jünger war,
habe ich oft den Zug genommen,
weil ich keinen Führerschein hatte.
Und wenn ich die Zugkontrolleure
gesehen habe,
habe ich sie
aussergewöhnlich gefunden.
Sie hatten eine gute Präsenz,
sie konnten mehrere Sprachen -
das fand ich grossartig.
Früher, wenn die Kontrolleure
reingekommen sind,
hatte ich die Tickets immer bereit.
Yann ist immer noch Feuer und Flamme
für seinen Job,
auch wenn der sehr wohl
seine Schattenseiten hat.
Der schwierigste Teil
sind Personenunfälle.
Wenn der Zug angehalten wird,
während die Leiche entfernt wird,
und die Polizei kommt,
dann können wir die Leute
nicht aus dem Zug lassen.
Es kann lange dauern.
Es gibt Leute,
die ein Flugzeug erwischen müssen,
Leute,
die etwas Wichtiges vorhaben.
In dieser Situation muss man sich
mit dem Lokomotivführer absprechen.
Man muss schauen,
ob die Person noch lebt.
Es ist mir schon passiert,
dass die Person unter dem Zug
noch gelebt hat.
Solche Situationen
sind psychologisch am schwierigsten.
Es ist 13.30 Uhr.
Der Volg in Laax
läuft aussergewöhnlich gut,
obwohl die anderen grossen Läden
nur fünf Autominuten entfernt sind.
Was ist Judiths Geheimnis?
Präsenz zeigen.
Ich mache während des Tages
immer wieder Runden durch den Laden.
Dann sehen die Leute,
dass ich hier bin und arbeite.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Die Leute schätzen auch, dass
ich sehe, dass sie hier einkaufen.
Ich bin auch sehr dankbar dafür.
Das spüren die Leute, denke ich.
Und dann unterstützen sie dich.
Trotzdem -
seit 1995 sind in der Schweiz
fast 3'000 Dorfläden verschwunden.
Was ist ein Dorf ohne Laden?
Das ist nicht nur
die Sicht als Verkäuferin.
Ich lebe auch in einem Dorf.
Ich werde auch mal alt.
Ich will nicht alles
per Internet bestellen,
und dann kommt dieses Päckchen,
und fertig.
Ich will diesen Kontakt
mit den Leuten.
Um 14 Uhr beginnt in Bellinzona
die Sitzung des Kantonsparlaments.
Seit drei Jahren
ist Sebastiano mit dabei.
Die Männer sind hier mit 75 %
immer noch deutlich übervertreten.
Schon der Fakt,
dass hier nicht jeder rein darf,
erzeugt bei mir Emotionen.
Ich erinnere mich noch,
als ich im Mai 2015
das erste Mal hier hereinkam.
Und ich empfinde
immer noch das Gleiche.
Die Liberalen
stellen mit 24 Abgeordneten
die grösste Fraktion
im 90-köpfigen Parlament.
Sebastiano ist ein grosser Verfechter
des Schweizer Milizsystems.
Heute Morgen war ich in Colombera
mit Stiefeln an den Füssen
unterwegs, um Messungen vorzunehmen,
und heute Nachmittag bin ich hier,
um das Gesetz
über den Grossen Rat zu diskutieren.
Das ist für mich Milizpolitik.
Wenn die Politik
von Menschen gemacht wird,
die von hier sind
und die die Probleme der Bevölkerung
selbst erleben,
dann können sie ihren Beitrag
auf politischer Ebene
für das Gemeinwohl
viel besser leisten.
Auch Yann engagiert sich
für die Allgemeinheit,
allerdings auf ganz anderer Ebene.
Das tut gut.
Wenn sein Sohn keine Zeit hat,
nutzt er den Nachmittag fürs Joggen.
Er trainiert für einen Marathon und
sammelt Geld für autistische Kinder.
Ich habe Glück,
dass ich in Genf geboren wurde.
Ich bin gesund, ich habe einen Job,
ich habe ein fabelhaftes Kind.
Alles läuft gut.
Man muss nicht weit gehen.
Nebenan gibt es Menschen,
die in Not sind,
die krank sind
oder alles verloren haben.
Ich möchte ihnen helfen.
Yangdol
wohnt in einem Vorort von Luzern.
Weil ihr Mann Ferien hat,
muss sie ihren Sohn
heute nicht von der Krippe abholen.
Das erste Mal habe ich geweint,
weil ich ihn so sehr vermisst habe.
Obwohl ich ihn ja am Abend
und in der Nacht sehen kann.
Aber ich habe ihn trotzdem vermisst.
Wenn ich mit der Arbeit fertig bin,
mache ich ganz schnell,
damit ich
möglichst schnell zu Hause bin.
(Kind) Mama!
- Hallo.
Hast du auf mich gewartet?
* Sie spricht tibetisch. *
Yangdols Mann ist Koch
und ebenfalls als Flüchtling
mit seinen Eltern
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Kennengelernt haben sich die beiden
2009 an einem tibetischen Fest.
Londen
war sofort fasziniert von Yangdol.
Ich habe versucht,
ihre Nummer zu kriegen,
habe einen Kollegen gefragt
und dann die Nummer bekommen.
Ich habe mit ihm geschimpft und
gefragt: "Warum rufst du mich an?"
Ich hatte solche Angst.
All diese Leute
waren fremd für mich.
Ich habe es etwa nach einer Woche
wieder versucht.
Dann hat sie es langsam
ein bisschen ernst genommen.
Dann haben wir langsam begonnen,
am Telefon zu reden.
Fünf Jahre später
haben die beiden geheiratet.
Weil Yangdol
noch Flüchtlingsstatus hatte,
durfte sie erst nach der Heirat von
der Ostschweiz nach Luzern ziehen.
* Sie spricht tibetisch. *
Judiths Zehnstünder ist bald um.
Sie rechnet ab.
Obwohl sie
ein Leben lang gearbeitet hat,
hätte sie sich früher eine
solche Verantwortung nicht zugetraut.
Heute weiss ich,
was ich leisten kann.
Und dann fordere ich auch ein,
was ich will.
Aber früher war das nicht so.
Ich habe oft Sachen gemacht,
die ich nicht hätte machen müssen.
Für wenig.
Aber ja, so ist es.
Vieles hat ihrer Meinung nach
auch mit dem Rollenbild
in der Gesellschaft zu tun.
Männer und Frauen
werden nicht gleich behandelt.
Als Mann hast du es oft einfacher.
Frauen machen eher Arbeiten,
die Männer nicht machen.
Das sieht man im Verkauf.
Wir haben sehr, sehr viele Frauen
im Verkauf - viel mehr als Männer.
Es sind halt
nicht so lukrative Jobs.
Und ein Mann ...
Wenn ein Mann etwas sagt,
ist es ein Mann, der es gesagt hat.
Eine Frau braucht immer viel mehr
Kraft, um sich durchzusetzen.
Yann hat noch etwas vor heute.
Er singt schon lange in einer Band.
Die Proben finden in einem Parkhaus
in Genf statt.
# Et tout autour de moi
# aucun regard a séché.
# Et tout au fond de moi,
je m'oblige a resister,
# de ne pas croire
en cette tristesse,
# d'être indifférent.
# Et je crois que j'ai oublié
le plus important.
Ich hatte schon schlechte Zeiten.
Mit 18 war ich sehr nervös
und hatte mit allen Streit.
Meine Beziehung zu meinen Eltern
war sehr kompliziert.
Ich habe mich
in der Schule geprügelt.
Die Nacht hat mich sehr inspiriert,
ich habe angefangen zu schreiben.
Und das ist mir geblieben.
Ich schreibe noch oft nachts.
Das gefällt mir sehr.
# Je n'ai pas pris le temps
de pleurer.
# Je n'ai pas pris le temps.
# Je n'ai pas pris le temps
de me laisser ...
Eines der Lieder hat er damals
für seine kranke Mutter geschrieben.
Ich habe dieses Lied
an einem Konzert gespielt.
Das hat mir gut getan.
Und es gab Leute, die am Ende
des Konzerts sehr bewegt waren
und zu mir kamen, um mir zu sagen,
dass dieses Lied sie sehr anspricht.
Und ich fand das grossartig.
Mit eigenen Worten, eigenen Gefühlen
kann man etwas teilen,
mit anderen etwas gemeinsam haben.
Die Freude an der Musik
teilt er aber v.a. auch
mit den anderen Bandmitgliedern.
Wir teilen hier etwas Grossartiges.
Mein Leben ist ja immer Teilen.
Das ist super.
Singen macht mich leer, aber es
erfüllt mich auch mit Emotionen.
Und es bringt mich dazu,
weiterzumachen.
# Il n'est pas dans le noir,
il n'est pas dans le blanc,
# il est dans les nuages ...
Yangdol sitzt ihre Vergangenheit
immer noch in den Knochen.
Sie wurde nach einer Demonstration
von der Polizei verfolgt.
Ihre Eltern
haben ihr zur Flucht verholfen.
Sie hat sich ganz allein
auf den Weg gemacht.
Als ich vom Tibet gekommen bin, habe
ich dieses Foto immer dabeigehabt.
Mein Vater hat mir gesagt:
"Nimm das mit!"
"Das unterstützt dich unterwegs."
Das ist einfach ein Glauben.
Das habe ich immer dabei.
Es war schwierig.
Von Tibet bis Bhutan bin ich zu Fuss
gegangen. Es dauerte ca. vier Tage.
Von Bhutan bis Nepal
war es nicht so schlimm,
weil es Verkehrsmittel gibt.
Ich war ein paar Monate in Nepal.
Und von dort bis hierher bin ich
mit der Hilfe eines Mannes gekommen.
Als ich mit ihm unterwegs war,
hatte ich wirklich grosse Angst.
Ich kannte ihn überhaupt nicht.
Und ich sah zum ersten Mal
einen Weissen mit blonden Haaren.
Das war komisch für mich.
Aber die Familie hat mir gesagt: "Du
musst gehen, du bist illegal hier."
Ich hatte keine andere Wahl.
"Wenn du hier bleibst,
kommst du ins Gefängnis."
Das wollte ich nicht.
Dann ging ich also
mit diesem Mann mit.
Ich hatte immer Angst.
Den ganzen Weg habe ich nur gebetet.
Um 19.30 Uhr in Zignau.
Judith hat Feierabend.
Früher war immer viel Betrieb
in ihrem Haus.
Jetzt wohnen fünf Katzen und nur noch
das jüngste von vier Kindern hier.
Hallo, Cara.
- Hallo, Mami.
Sie und ihre Tochter geben sich heute
praktisch die Klinke in die Hand.
Auch Judith
muss schon bald wieder los.
Sie ist im Dorf als Präsidentin
des Samaritervereins sehr engagiert
und hilft auch im Frauenverein mit.
Zudem macht sie Musik.
Die Proben beginnen um 20 Uhr.
* Kirchenglockenschläge *
Sebastiano
hat es knapp auf die nächste Sitzung
zurück in seine Gemeinde Breggia
geschafft.
Gut. Guten Abend alle zusammen.
Wir können unsere
übliche Gemeindesitzung beginnen.
Ich möchte Sie höflichst bitten,
das Zimmer zu verlassen.
* Kirchenglockenschläge *
Judith hat Musikprobe.
Sie spielt gleich in zwei Dorfmusiken
und singt noch im Kirchenchor mit.
Drei Abende pro Woche
sind so bereits verbucht.
Viele engagieren sich halt nicht
oder wollen nur konsumieren.
Etwas zu machen
ist immer schwieriger.
Man kann dann auch
etwas falsch machen.
Aber man macht wenigstens etwas.
Das versuche ich
ein bisschen vorzuleben.
Vielleicht macht es ja
der eine oder andere nach.
In der Dorfmusik Sumvitg Cumpadials
machen auch zwei ihrer Söhne mit.
Beni dirigiert, ich geniesse das.
Michi spielt Schlagzeug.
Wir sind so wenige Momente zusammen,
aber diesen Moment
haben wir zusammen.
Pause.
In Luzern. Yangdol geniesst mit
ihrer kleinen Familie den Feierabend.
Ihr ist es recht,
wenn nicht viel läuft.
* Tiergeräusch *
Hauptsache, sie können
Zeit miteinander verbringen.
Früher war ich allein und ledig
und hatte niemanden hier.
Jetzt habe ich
meinen Mann und meinen Sohn,
die mich unterstützen können.
Bis jetzt läuft es sehr gut.
Und in Zukunft
möchte ich noch eine Tochter.
Good boy!
# Mini Farb und dini,
# das sind zäme zwe,
# wärets
drü, vier, füüf, sächs, sibe,
# wo gern wettet zäme blibe
# gits en Rägeboge,
wo sich cha lo gseh,
wo sich cha lo gseh.
Gute Nacht.
- Tschüss!
Fertig gespielt. Um 20.30 Uhr
ist Nachtruhe für die ganze Familie.
Yangdol muss morgen um 5.30 Uhr
wieder raus.
Es nachtet ein im Bündnerland.
Bei einem Bier in der Dorfbeiz
lässt Judith den Tag ausklingen.
Yann ist ausgepowert, aber zufrieden.
Morgen muss er wieder früh raus.
So.
Morgen muss ich um 3 Uhr aufstehen.
Dann geht es nach Italien.
Schön.
Sogar Sebastiano
kommt endlich zur Ruhe.
In seinem Restaurant
hat seine Frau noch etwas zu essen
für ihn beiseite gestellt.
Jetzt ist es 0.20 Uhr.
Davon habe ich immer geträumt.
Nach Hause kommen, müde von der
Arbeit, ohne das Gefühl zu haben,
dass ich nicht alles getan habe,
was ich hätte tun können.
Meine Frau im Bett umarmen.
Ich denke, das ist das Beste,
was du dir wünschen kannst.
Ein Tag im Leben der Schweiz
geht zu Ende.
Ciao, buona notte.
Morgen stehen sie wieder auf.
Und mit ihnen mehr als 8 Mio.
andere Menschen in der Schweiz.
Jeder mit seinem Alltag
und mit seiner Geschichte.
Nächste Woche: Kurt Fischer
fegt Kamine im Mittelland,
Valentina Andrej
produziert Biowein im Wallis,
Alex Beauval steuert Dampfschiffe
über den Genfersee
und Beryl Jost betreut Kinder
in einem Zürcher Hort.